Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE is a full
throated supporter of Donald Trump's big lie.
And unlike most Republican politicians who simply
pay lip service to the idea that Trump was robbed
and Biden committed voter fraud along with
the Democrats. I actually do believe that
GREENE believes this conspiracy theory because
she's never met a conspiracy theory that she
didn't like. And she loves Donald Trump so
much. You smash those things together and
poof, you have someone who is going to fall for
the big lie. Well, the Georgia congresswoman
is now making the case that this midterm season,
in order to fight the massive amounts of voter
fraud that's supposedly being committed by
the left, Republican voters have to go out and
vote not just once, but maybe two or three times
now. She could have been making a joke here, but
even if so, she probably shouldn't be saying
it. And we'll get to why exactly in a little
bit. But first, here's the clip of her saying it.
Speaker 4: I've heard find support. People like
Representative GREENE, get out and vote with
you and your 20 closest friends and neighbors
in November and vote 1 to 3, whatever the
law allows you to do. Which in Georgia is
almost anything. So you never know right now.
Thank you so much for being here, for the hope,
for your fight and for communicating
with us. We appreciate you as well.
Thank you. Thanks so much.
Speaker 1: Well, good for Mallory Staples, at
least for jumping in there and saying, hold on, we
don't encourage any lawbreaking. Do whatever the
law will allow you to do. But then again, the two
are making it sound like the law will allow you
to do anything. In Georgia. You can vote multiple
times and all of these different things like it's
one big joke, right? That's not good for trust
in our democratic process. Now, this reminds
me of the 2020 election during the presidential
campaign, when Donald Trump went to North Carolina
and he told people to submit an absentee ballot
and then also to go to the polls in person and
try to vote that way, which, yes, is very much
a crime that would be voting twice. And that's
actual voter fraud, which you can't get away
with. It was arguably a crime for Donald
Trump to encourage this as well. But surprise,
surprise, he didn't face any consequences for it.
Speaker 5: 600,000 people could vote by absentee
in this state. Are you are you confident in that?
Well, they'll go out and they'll vote and they're
going to have to go and check their vote by going
to the polling, voting that way, because if it if
it tabulates and they won't be able to do that. So
let them send it in and let them go vote. And
if their assistance is good, as they say it is,
then obviously they won't be able to vote. If it
isn't tabulated, they'll be able to vote. So this
is the way it is and that's what they should do.
Speaker 1: Now, the problem when people like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Donald Trump go out and
make statements like this is that people actually
take their word for it and act upon it. We've seen
a number of examples from the 2020 election of
people doing this. Here's just a few residents
of Trump loving retirement community arrested
for allegedly voting twice in 2020 election. This
took place at the Villages in Florida. And then we
have a Republican official in Ohio facing charges
for voting twice in the November election. There's
plenty more examples. We've covered them on the
show over the past couple of years. And it makes
sense, right, because these Republican voters want
to take action in their own hands. They think that
the Democrats are doing this left and right. So
they might as well fight fire with fire and vote
two or three times themselves even. Though there's
no basis for the claims that Donald Trump and his
supporters have been making about the voter fraud
issue. And I wouldn't be surprised if in the 2022
midterms we see even more examples, right, because
they've really ramped up the rhetoric about
supposed voter fraud over the last couple of
years. And so I'm sure we'll have dozens to talk
about for you after the midterms are over with.
And when confronted with how people are doing
this on Republicans behalf, I'm sure Marjorie
Taylor GREENE will just laugh it off or claim
that it's not happening, or she'll just ignore
it altogether. But it's incredibly irresponsible
for Marjorie Taylor GREENE to do this, and I'm
sure she doesn't care at all. All right. We're
going to throw to a break. We'll be back with
much more of the David Pakman show after this.